[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اعلن ملك شركه باجناريف جيني
بريكوجين ان قوته سيطرت على كامله مدينه
سوليدار وقال بريغوجن في حسابه على
التليجرام هنا وحدته فاجنر سيطرت على
كامري اراضي سوريا دار وان القتال لا يزال
مستمرا وسط المدينه مع بعض القوات
الاوكرانيه المحاصره مع استمرار عمليات
التمشيط فيها وكانت نائبته وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني قد قالت ان الجيش الاوكرانيه لا
يزال يدافع عن مواقع في سوريا دار
من جانبه قال الرئيس الاوكراني
الوضع في دونيتسك بتصعب للغايه ويتطلب
مستوى جديدا من المساعدات العسكريه التي
يقدمها شركاء بلاده
زارت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه بشكل مفاجئ
لمدينه هالكيف ذو شرقيه اوكرانيا بالقرب
من خطوط القتال الاماميه وبعده الوزيره
الالمانيه بتقديم مزيد من الاسلحه
بالاضافه الى ما سمتها عروض ملموسه
لمساعدتها على الانضمام الى الاتحاد
وستتحافظ على جاهزيته القتاليه كضامن
لسيادته وسلامه اراضيها واشدد على ان
روسيا تخطط ايضا لتوسيع سنه استحتها
الهجوميه الحديثه في المستقبل القريب
وقع رؤساء الاتحاد الاوروبي والامينو
العام لخلف الناتو يعنينا المشتركا
للتعاوني والتنسيق ردا على ما سمياه اخطر
تهديد للامن منذ عقود يتضمن الاعلان
والتزام الطرفين بدمي اوكرانيا في مواجهه
روسيا ضمن الحرب الدائره هناك كما تطرق
الاعلان الى الصين لاول مره ووصفها
بالتحدي لمبادئ الشريكين في مواجهته عالم
نيورادو تغييره
مجلس الامن الروسيني روسيا تقاتل انا حلفا
شمال الاطلسي في اوكرانيا بحسب تعبيره
واضاف ان الغربه يريد نحو روسيا من خريطه
العالم وان الحرب في اوكرانيا هي مواجهه
افادت روترز بان الرئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناك ونظيره الياباني
اليوم يسمح والتفاهم بتبادل نشر القوات من
الدوله
الدفاعيه مع اليابان مهم للغ ده لتعزيز
التزامات البلدين في المحيطين الهنديين
والهادئ
اعتبار العياش الهمامي منسق وهيئه الدفاع
عن القضاه المعزولين في تونس ان احالته
للتحقيق على خلفيه تصريح اعلاميه تندرج في
طري سياسه رئيس البلاد وحكمته في التعاطي
مع المختلفين معه في الراي اضافه لمحاوله
تغطيه على ملف القضاه المعزولين
وقد اتهم نقيب الصحه فينا التونسيين محمد
المهدي الجلاس هي السلطاته بتحويل البلاد
تدريجيا الى سجن كبير للراي على حد قوله
اينما كنتم طاب توقعاتكم بكل خير